le sommet du mont-blanc 4810 mètres
d'altitude le toit de l'europe
quelle belle tribune pour dire à tout le
monde qu'il ya plein de choses qui sont
possibles tout est possible maladie ou
pas santé ou pas tout est possible selon
blanc c'était un rêve c'était mon rêve
c'était notre rêve
jérémy nicolas david françois lhoro tous
ensemble
c'était notre haine ça faisait quatre
ans qu'on s'entraînait pour ça
trois tentatives qui sont arrêtés à 4500
mètres d'altitude
et puis moi pendant quatre ans tous les
jours à chaque instant le mont blanc je
l'avais là devant les yeux il était là
tous les jours je mange et dort mont
blanc je dormais mont blanc où j'allais
au petit coin mont blanc faisait que ça
toutes les actions que je posais toutes
les questions que je me posais je me
laisse supposer pour le mont blanc et
puis j'en ai eu des frissons j'en ai eu
les larmes aux yeux et j'en ai des poils
devenue une boule au ventre une espèce
d'énergie comme ça là j'ai pensé tous
les jours et on est arrivé au sommet
c'était fabuleux c'était fantastique
c'est impossible aussi ça et c'était
notre rêve
vous connaissez certainement mais cinq
blessures
les cinq pardon les cinq regret des
personnes en fin de vie
c'est une infirmière australienne il
s'appelle boni war cas détectés ces cinq
regrets qui s'est tenue au chevet des
débats des packs des personnes en fin de
vie et ses 5 regret donc j'aurais aimé
travailler ou à durrës genre à aimer
autorisés à être heureux j'aurais aimé à
vivre la vie que j'ai envie de vivre et
pas celle que les autres attendent de
moi j'aurais aimé exprimer mes
sentiments j'aurais aimé conserver mes
amis 5 regrets moi je vous dis tout de
suite hein les gars et filles et c'est
que les regrets c'est bon c'est pas
négociable
c'est pas négociable la fatalité la
résignation c'est pas mon truc c'est pas
mon truc
il n'y a pas moyen et qui dit regrets
dit rêve qui n'a pas arrêté réalisé là
il ya cinq rêve qui n'ont pas été règne
c'est pas acceptable c'est carrément
donné un nom donné quand vous êtes chez
bb ce petit bébé la cas prenez un marché
qui est tombée des dizaines de fois
encore et encore il est tombé 10 fois
mais il s'est relevé à chaque fois il
s'est relevé il s'est relevé des
centaines de fois il s'est relevé encore
encore encore encore encore encore
encore encore vous êtes relevé toi tu
t'es relevé toi tu t'es relevé pas aussi
est un moment donné entre ce petit bébé
et ce passage là vous êtes perdus
vous êtes laissé croire que le bonheur
c'était pas pour vous l'amour c'était
pas pour vous méritiez pas tout à fait
et puis mon rêve pas pour vous non plus
pour les autres et moi j'ai envie de
vous poser une seule question
aujourd'hui
et puis il y aura plusieurs une seule
question mais celle que la question que
je vous pose et la maintenance et à quel
moment est-ce que vous avez cessé de
croire vos rêves à qeynos musée vous ce
que vous avez cessé de croire en vos
rêves d'enfants en l'amour de croire en
l'amour également c'est maintenant que
ça se passe c'est maintenant que ça se
joue et tout est possible
je suis convaincu qu'un
je suis convaincu que le job idéal il
existe le job idéal il existe j'aime
beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup cette phrase aussi donne
de jean marc schaal d'une marche à lydie
les rêves d'aujourd'hui sur la réalité
de demain c'est à dire que j'adore cette
phrase c'est à dire que ce que vous
pouvez rêver aujourd'hui déjà ça existe
si on peut le penser c'est que ça existe
quelque part forcément dans le monde
c'est sûr c'est une règle les rêves
d'aujourd'hui sur la réalité de demain
tout ce que vous pouvez rêver
aujourd'hui il y en a d'autres qui
pourront le faire demain à votre place
si vous passez pas à l'action et moi
j'ai pas envie de me dire à 90 ans j'ai
pas envie de voir les autres réaliser
mes rêves j'ai pas envie de ne pas avoir
tout tenté pour être heureux de pouvoir
tout tenté pour continuer à pouvoir
briller cette petite flamme d'espoir
tout au fond là-bas tout tenté pour m'en
sortir
c'est moi c'est moi les rêves
d'aujourd'hui sur l'arrivée de demain ce
sera formidable les autres ils vont
réaliser vos rêves
bravo c'est général ils seront heureux
mes joueurs je veux pas regretter ça
et je parlais le job idéal le job idéal
la première chose c'est adidas dire
c'est que le travail idéal le travail de
vos rêves il existe imaginez un monde où
vous avez un manager cas c'est un boulot
sur lui-même il a fait il a travaillé
sur ses peurs ses croyances ses valeurs
il a compris que à la base de toutes ces
valeurs
parce que nos valeurs elles viennent de
là à la base de toutes nos valeurs
celles concorde tout et tout les autres
c'est l'amour est un
il imprime ses valeurs cette vision
d'entreprise à son entreprise
il a créé un produit un service dans ce
but les est conçu dans l'amour se
produit service et vinifié il bénéficie
à tous au bien-être de tous ce produit a
été conçu dans l'amour il respecte
humain il respecte la faune et respecte
la fleur c'est génial et de
collaborateurs mais il est content de
venir bosser il a le sourire parce que
ça donne un sens à sa vie
ça donne un sens à son travail et puis
en même temps il contribue à quelque
chose de grand il ya de l'amour derrière
c'est génial le client lui il a vu la
pub à la télé il est amoureux du produit
il arrive devant le magasin
j'ai le sourire le portefeuille le
porte-monnaie grands ouverts j'attends
que ça et moi je suis convaincu que
c'est pas cette vision du travail
remettent de la ruhr dans le travail
quand je parle d'amour ge du l'envi la
passion
c'est tout forcément s'il ya de l'amour
il ya de la confiance également parce
que les mecs qu'ils ont été recrutés par
le manager dans sur les mêmes valeurs
sur l'a7 même vision donc forcément il
ya de la confiance derrière y'a même pas
besoin de les contrôler ça se fait tout
seul et si tout ça ça se fait dans
l'amour je suis convaincu que c'est la
seule solution pour arriver à régler les
défis de ce siècle les défis de demain
aujourd'hui on parle de réchauffement
climatique de pollution sortie du
pétrole gestion des déchets ici il ya
une deuxième question aussi que j'ai pas
envie qu'on me pose ou à laquelle je
pense dans tous les cas c'est c'est
celle de mon fils j'ai pas l'enfant
c'est pas forcément facile d'avoir des
emplois dans mon cas mais ça arrivera
c'est celle de mon fils ou de mon petit
fils un jour tu vas me dire mais papa
papilles qu'est ce que tu as fais toi
pour éviter ça qu'est ce que vous avez
fait vous pour éviter ça
quelques races vous allez laisser sur
terre à part un tas de déchets
abandonner une balance parce que ça
forcément va le laisser derrière moi il
ya une balance d'un côté pas trop et
google et puis à tout le positif que
vous allez laisser à quoi vous servez à
part à produire des déchets c'est ça la
question tu me pose donc le travail le
travail la solution d'un travail c'est
l'amour j'en suis convaincu
je suis convaincu ou d'autant qu' on a
tous l'amour en nous en fait y'a pas de
mauvaises personnes
il ya que des gens qui ont peur qu'on
des fausses croyances des barrières
limitantes et quand juste besoin d'un
petit peu de courage pour affronter tout
ça on a tous les mêmes valeurs rochon
nous c'est certain
c'est juste notre ego quand swiss à
sundhouse un tas de peur de problèmes de
soucis et s'est enfui tout au fond de
notre coeur
mais on a tous les mêmes var on est tous
les mêmes valeurs et un une personne qui
vous fait du mal c'est une personne qui
a peur c'est une personne qui souffre il
souffre beaucoup plus que vous quand
elle vous fait du mal maintenant et vous
cette souffrance vous la connaissez
cette peur vous la connaissez pas ce que
vous l'avez vécu donc ça y est cette
personne qui vous fait du mal elle
s'ouvre elle souffrait en fait on a tous
les mêmes valeurs on a tous la ruhr en
nous mêmes trump axa bonne
une kim jong-il vous aurez du nord et
même magie
pas lui
vous savez le moustachu là et voilà même
c'est à dire que peut-être qu'il va
falloir creuser longtemps mais longtemps
et peut-être caf a recruté creuser
creuser encore et encore et encore mais
forcément un moment donné on va trouver
de l'amour en vidant son petit coeur
étriqué c'est obligé parce que le mec il
était bébé un jour avec des petits yeux
de bébé avec des petites joues bébé on
m'a dit pas faire ça parce que ça allait
perturber le font et où il faisait des
petits bisous et xix des gazouillis et
forcément il ya de l'amour en lui c'est
obligé c'est peut-être le mec qui a le
plus peur de toute la terre en fête
chercher à se libérer de ses peurs à
100% qu'elles soient conscientes ou
inconscientes
je suis certain également que c'est
possible parce que le 1er juillet quand
vous étiez peut-il dès le premier jour
des grandes banques or il y avait le
ciel bleu il faisait chaud les petites
feuilles dans les arbres et où on était
bien un
et puis on était assis par terre alors
il y en a qui regardaient les concode
qu'il gardait les avions donc si j'ai
regardé les avions mais je jouais aussi
que des pierres un feu comme tout le
monde j'ai cherché des fossiles et jour
là bas c'était le premier jour des
grandes vacances et on avait l'éternité
devant nous et moi je respirais à 100%
parce que j'étais dans treize ans jeté
par passé j'étais pas dans le futur
j'étais là
avec l'amplitude maximale autant alain
speak alex pire est donc la maladie et
là pas de place pour s'exprimer je suis
convaincu que la maladie ne procure la
place que je lui laisse pas dire que je
faisais je vais aller chercher jusqu'à
la moindre alvéoles pulmonaires les
disponibles dans les poumons sont autant
elle inspire quel expert
elle n'existe pas donc plus je suis
travaille sur mes peurs moi je suis
stressé peluche dans l'instant et donc
non je respire je suis convaincu que se
libérer de ses peurs à 100% c'est
possible je suis convaincu qu'un
incarner ses valeurs ou les a vu tout à
l'heure
l'amour l'espoir la vérité la liberté la
quête de sens le bien-être la joie à
chaque instant c'est possible parce que
c'est toujours pareil quand jacques
hardelay mes valeurs je respirais à 100%
j'en suis certain dans le présent n'y a
pas de malade il n'y a pas de problème
il n'y a pas de souci la mort elle
n'existait pas dans le présent il ya que
la joie la santé et l'amour donc
incarner ses valeurs à 100% à chaque
instant c'est possible ne pas chercher
incarner ses valeurs ne pas respecter
ses valeurs au quotidien c'est perdre
son temps sur terre
continuent à vivre dans ces peurs à se
laisser drivée par ses peurs c'est
perdre son temps sur terre et en parlant
de valeur j'ai rencontré ma chérie un
atelier sur les valeurs à paris et la
femme idéale elle existe la femme idéale
elle existe je vous ai tout à l'heure il
ya de l'amour en chacun de nous s'il
faut rencontrer 99 tonna avant de
rencontrer la bonne personne
et bien vous allez rencontrer ses 99
personnes
ai-je de la première jusqu'à la 99ème
croyez toujours au fond de vous que la
personne extraordinaire elle existe que
l'ami extraordinaire que la familiale le
mec idéal il existe il ya sept milliards
d'êtres humains sur terre
l'effort que sémantique pas il suffit
d'être où il suffit d'être vrai
authentique de ce livre et ça va venir
tout seul suffit d'y croire
la femme idéale c'est génial
elle sème elle saine je m'aime elle sème
elle a envie de changer parce qu'elles
s'aiment
elle change tout seul j'ai même pas
besoin de la changer elle fait la
vaisselle parce qu'elle sait mais fait
le ménage parce qu'elle sait mais elle
prend soin de son corps parce qu'elles
s'aiment
lui aussi je fais le ménage parce que je
m'aime mais je prends soin de son corps
de sa santé parce qu'elle sème j'ai rien
à faire et qu'elle cherche à incarner
ses valeurs parce qu'elle sème également
c'est génial ça existe c'est possible
c'est possible et je convaincu également
qu'un même si bon médecin le dire que
c'est impossible
respirez à 100% c'est possible il va me
dire que mes pourront ils sont détruits
peut-être car sept milliards d'êtres
humains à six ou sept milliards d'êtres
humains qui vont venir des poumons ils
sont détruits tu peux rien y faire
j'en ai rien à général un coude
parce que ce qui compte c'est que je
suis là devant vous ce soir
ce qui compte c'est que j'ai fait quatre
marathons ce qui compte c'est que j'ai
été au sommet du mont blanc le 22 juin
que j'ai fait tout ce que j'ai fait et
peu importe si c'est vrai ou si c'est
pas vrai en fait l'espoir l'amour quoi
c'est un choix si la volonté je m'en
fous est ce que vous pensez
moi je suis là et c'est ce qui fait que
d'actions actions de petits pains petit
pas que je fais je me rapproche de mon
objectif et je continue à y croire et
qu'il est toujours là
peu importe c'est vraiment pas beaucoup
je sais que je vais y arriver puisque
j'arrive à l'imaginer c'est que je vais
y arriver c'est que ça existe c'est
possible c'est comme changer mon adn
changer mon adn
je suis convaincu que c'est possible je
suis convaincu qu'un donc ça c'est une
certitude déjà dans mon sens que mon
point de vue c'est qu'un cancer c'est
une mutation génétique localiser un
cancer à mon sens ça se crée alors bien
sûr il ya l'environnement extérieur mais
aussi tout ce que vous mangez ce que
vous buvez vous fumez l'air que vous
respirez le niveau de stress que vous
infligez votre hygiène de vie le sport
hooper qui entrent en ligne de compte
également un cancer s'inscrire et un
cancer c'est s'inscrit ça peut s'enlever
des exemples autour de nous des
personnes qu'on guérit du cancer sans
faire jamais de chez mieux ça existe il
y en a à la pelle suffit de demander à
google ou de regarder les vidéos tedx et
si on peut enlever un cancer une
mutation génétique localisée mais on
doit pouvoir faire ça au niveau du corps
tout entier c'est évident c'est sur les
rêves d'aujourd'hui sur la réalité de
demain
mon père il ya cinquante ans à l'école
ils apprenaient pas la tectonique des
plaques
il atteindrait ils apprenaient la
théorie fixiste des continents
n'hésitez pas c'est à dire 50 ans était
hier qu'est ce qu'on dira dans 50 ans à
propos de la génétique
la science c'est pas un dogme c'est pas
une religion
il sent on y croit trop souvent la
médecine padox pas une religion non plus
comment on fait pour un pour continuer à
incarner l'espoir à vivre l'espoir
incarné ces valeurs à chaque instant
c'est un travail de chaque instant comme
je vous dis c'est une traque ses tracks
et l'amour par fourre tout dans l'autre
autour de vous traquer ce qui est beau à
quoi on sert si c'est pas pour espérer
si ce n'est pas pour envoyer de
l'optimist du positif et de l'amour dans
le monde
on est là pour ça on est là pour ça et
l'action l'action qui à faire tout ce
qu'il a à faire c'est d'avancer d'agir
se remette en question agir sur mais pas
question agir on l'a déjà dit tout à
l'heure se remette en question
agir se remette en question agir tous
les jours tous les jours tous les jours
je teste des choses tous les jours parce
que je considère sur la spécialiste de
la maladie dure une petite pour le
médecin et que moi aussi je peux faire
plein de choses dès maintenant et sans
attendre
c'est moi qui décide ce que je peux
faire tout ce que je peux pas faire
c'est pas mon médecin
c'est en cours - non non a dit l'action
plus vous agissiez plus vous rapprocher
de votre haine et
enfin pour finir la troisième dernière
question que je vous pose est c'est quel
type de cette intervention jusqu'où êtes
vous prêts à aimer parce que respecter
ses rennes il règne là ils viennent de
là c'est écouter son coeur respecter ses
rêves cessé mais respecter ces règles
c'est respecter ce qu'on a
jusqu'où êtes vous prêts à aimer
jusqu'où êtes vous prêt à vous aimer
merci